una recta secante se intersecta con la
curva bien igual al lugar y natural de x
en dos puntos cuyas coordenadas en la
variable x son m y más h cuál es la
pendiente de la recta secante y tal vez
no podría ser inmediatamente obvio pero
nos dan dos puntos
de hecho aquí tenemos dos puntos y por
lo tanto podemos calcular la pendiente
de esta recta secante porque si x vale m
ese es mi primer valor para x y entonces
tengo el punto
cómo y cuánto vale y bueno aquí nos lo
dicen y es igual al lugar y natural de
equis pero si x vale m entonces me
quedaría el logaritmo natural de en este
caso y ese sería mi primer punto y bueno
además tengo otro punto tengo otro valor
de x el valor de emmasa che entonces el
segundo punto sería el más h
y bueno cuánto vale james en este valor
de x bueno vale el logaritmo natural de
esto que tengo aquí el logaritmo natural
de
+ h ok y si ya tengo dos puntos entonces
voy a ser capaz de encontrar cuánto vale
la pendiente y observa estos dos puntos
estar sobre esta curva de esta función
pero además son puntos que viven en mi
recta secante porque son los puntos
donde la recta acercan te interese acá a
la curva por eso estos dos puntos están
en la recta y se conocen otros puntos
entonces cuál va a ser su pendiente
bueno recuerda que la pendiente
simplemente la pendiente es simplemente
el cambio en pie entre el cambio en x
así que hay que ver cuánto es el cambio
james y cuánto se cambió en x así que
esto a que va a ser igual bueno si vemos
al segundo punto como el punto final
entonces nuestro cambio en james sería
esta que tenemos aquí esto sería el
cambio en quien la diferencia entre
estos dos entonces me cambió en came
ser igual a quien bueno me va a quedar
el logaritmo natural de voy a tomarme a
éste como punto final
entonces me va a quedar más h
ya esto le voy a quitar el logaritmo
natural de bueno en este caso el natural
de el que por cierto ya sabemos cuánto
vale el logaritmo natural de en un
segundo voy a poner aquí su valor
ok ya todo esto lo vamos a dividir a
todo esto lo vamos a dividir entre el
cambio en x y como estoy diciendo que
este es mi punto final entonces este va
a ser mi cambio en x mi cambio en x
va a ser igual a la diferencia entre más
h
+ h ya esto le quitamos en ok esto está
de lujo pero se puede limpiar un poco
porque esta es su mamá y ésta está se
pueden ir y este logaritmo natural de m
es lo mismo que uno eso ya lo sabemos a
qué potencia tengo que elevar para que
me dé y bueno a la potencia 1 entonces
esto si lo limpiamos me va a quedar de
la siguiente manera me va a quedar el
logaritmo natural de m
+ h ok esto
- 1 - 1 y todo esto a su vez está
dividido entre bueno simplemente h /
simplemente h
y si observas tengo por aquí esta opción
que dice exactamente lo mismo así que
esta es mi opción correcta el lugar
natural de más h - 1 / h
ahora bien si lo que quieres hacer es
verlo de una manera más visual podemos
dibujar por aquí o unos ejes voy a
dibujar por aquí
y voy a dibujar por aquí mi eje x ok
dibujemos mis ejes y vamos a ver qué es
lo que está pasando en este problema
aquí tengo mi hija que por aquí tengo mi
eje x y voy a dibujar la función james
igual al logaritmo natural de x la voy a
poner con este color que igual el
logaritmo natural de x se va a ver más o
menos así es una función que empieza por
aquí va creciendo va creciendo y después
toman esta forma recuerdas toma esta
forma
se ve más o menos así ahora bien si por
aquí me tomo el valor de e
entonces este de kim es el punto y coma
logaritmo natural de m es decir el punto
y coma bueno 1 ok y si ahora por acá me
tomo a más h
supongamos que estamos justo por acá
éste es más h
entonces me estoy explicando también en
este otro punto me estoy fijando también
en este otro punto que sabemos que es el
más h
más h coma el lugar y natural de eso
mismo de más h
y si ahora me fijo en la pendiente de la
recta secante por estos dos puntos es
decir 1 a estos dos puntos y me fijo en
la pendiente de la recta secante que
pasa por ellos dos entonces puedo
fijarme en cuánto es el cambio en mi
cambio en james va a ir desde este valor
hasta este otro valor
es decir me va a quedar que me cambio
james déjame ponerlo así me cambio en
quien va a ser de aquí acá que se
observa va a ser la diferencia entre
estos dos me quedaría simplemente que me
cambio en game sería igual al logaritmo
natural de esto
+ h - 1
esto por una parte pero por otra parte
tengo que me cambio en x va a ser todo
esto que tenemos aquí y entonces esto me
va a quedar como el cambio en x va a ser
desde el hasta más h
lo cual es simplemente h y si me tomo la
división de entre estos dos de nuevo
diego a esta opción correcta y ya está
esta es la pendiente que estábamos
buscando